i have this rectangle here and i want to
figure out its area i want to figure out
how much space it is taking up on my
screen right over here and i encourage
you to pause this video and try to
figure out the area of this entire
rectangle and when you do it think about
the two different ways you could do it
you could either multiply the length of
the rectangle times the entire width so
just figure out the area of the entire
thing or you could separately figure out
the area of this red or this purple
rectangle and then separately figure out
this blue rectangle and realize that
they're combined areas is the exact same
thing as the entire rectangle so i
encourage you to pause the video and try
both of those both of those strategies
out
so let's just try them out ourselves
first let's look at the overall
dimensions of the larger rectangle the
length is nine
and we're going to multiply that times
the width but what's the width here well
the width is going to be eight
plus
that's this entire distance right over
here is 8 plus 12. so it's 9 times 8
plus 12
8 plus
12. this is one way that we could figure
out the area of this entire thing this
is just this is just the length times
the width 8 plus 12 is obviously going
to be equal to 20. but the other way
that we could do it and this must be
equivalent because we're figuring out
the area of the same thing is to
separate out the area of these two sub
rectangles so let's do that and this
must be equal to this thing so what's
the area of this purple rectangle well
it's going to be the length it's going
to be 9 let me do it in that same color
it's going to be 9
times the width which is eight it's
going to be nine
times
eight
and then what's the area of this blue
rectangle well that's going to be
nine
times so the height here is nine still
the height is 9 and what's the width
well the width is 12. the width is 12.
and what's the area of the combined if
you wanted to combine the area of the
purple rectangle and the blue one well
you just add these two things together
you would just add these two things
together and of course when you add
these two things together you get the
area of the entire thing so these things
must
be equivalent they are calculating the
same area now what's neat about this is
we just kind of showed ourselves the
distributive property the distributive
property when we're dealing with these
numbers you could try these out for any
numbers they'll work for any numbers
because the distributive property works
for any numbers you see when 9 times the
sum of 8 plus 12 is equal to 9 times 8
plus 9 times 12. we essentially have
distributed we have distributed the 9 9
times 8 plus
9 times 12. and let's actually calculate
it just to just to satisfy ourselves
about the area so if you multiply if you
multiply the length times the entire
width so that's 9 times 8 plus 12 that's
the same thing as 9 times 20 which is
180 and over here if you calculate the
area of this purple this purple
rectangle that is nine times eight so
that is going to be equal to 72
so that is going to be equal to 72
that's the purple rectangle area of the
blue rectangle 9 times 12 well that's
108
108 and we're going to take the sum of
the two to find the area of the larger
rectangle what is 72 plus 108 well 72
plus 108 is also equal to 180 so we
verify these indeed are equal to each
other when we calculate them and they
make sense because we are calculating
the same exact area